moving your arms and legs requires
planning by your nervous system and
action by your muscles the part of the
brain that does the planning is called
the posterior parietal cortex in here
different groups of neurons fire when
you imagine different movements now
researchers have been able to figure out
how to move a robotic arm just by
thinking about it
the researchers started by identifying
which neurons fire when a person
imagines a movement for example this
neuron fires when a man imagines
rotating his right shoulder but it turns
off when he imagines touching his nose
then the researchers connected specific
neurons in a person to the robotic arm
here a man who has lost the use of his
arms and legs moves a robotic arm for
the first time just by thinking about it
he can shake hands pick things up and
let them go this same technique can be
used to control a cursor on a computer
screen tapping into the brain like this
is the first step in connecting
complicated thoughts from our brain to
robotic limbs
you